en esta ocasión tengo la raíz cuadrada o
bueno espera la raíz principal de 1
entre 200 y lo que quiero hacer es
simplificar esto y cuando digo
simplificar me refiero a que voy a
buscar aquí sí hay cuadrados perfectos
para poder factorizar los y sacarlos del
radical así que te invito a que pausas
el vídeo y veas si lo puedes hacer por
tu cuenta
ok entonces una manera de ver esto es la
siguiente es decir bueno esto es
exactamente lo mismo que tomarme la raíz
cuadrada de 1 entre la raíz cuadrada de
200 y bueno la raíz cuadrada de 1
sabemos cuánto es la raíz cuadrada de 1
simple y sencillamente es 11 entre la
raíz cuadrada de 200 y lo que quiero
hacer es simplificar la raíz cuadrada de
200 y hay un par de formas para llegar
al resultado la primera es la siguiente
así que déjame anotarlo por aquí tengo
la raíz cuadrada
200 y la primera forma que quiero que
veamos es la siguiente
puedes darte cuenta de que 200 es
exactamente lo mismo que 2% que 2% y eso
nos va a servir bastante porque podemos
escribir esta raíz de la siguiente
manera esto es lo mismo que tomarme la
raíz cuadrada de 2 por 100
y bueno esto es exactamente lo mismo que
tomarme la raíz cuadrada de 2 que a su
vez multiplica a la raíz cuadrada de 100
y bueno que te des cuenta de que la raíz
cuadrada de 100 esto sea 10 así que en
lugar de esto voy a poner 10 y lo voy a
escribir de la siguiente manera esto me
va a quedar como 10 por la raíz cuadrada
de 2 10 por la raíz cuadrada de 2 bueno
esta es una forma de hacerlo pero bueno
si no te brinco de inmediato que 200 es
lo mismo que 2% y que siente era un
cuadrado perfecto entonces podemos
hacerlo con números más pequeños podemos
tomarnos otro
vamos a ver un método alternativo y para
eso voy a cambiar de color y voy a
utilizar se me ocurre este color y voy a
decir me voy a tomar la raíz cuadrada de
200 de 200 y vamos a factorizar este 200
bueno 200 es divisible entre 2 y estos
por 100 y si en este momento no te
brinca inmediatamente que 100 es un
cuadrado perfecto lo podemos factorizar
y para eso bueno se me ocurre que le
podemos sacar también mitad la mitad de
100 es 50 muy bien 50 también tiene
mitad así que vamos a factorizar los dos
que multiplican a 25 muy bien y si en
este momento no te brinca que 25 es un
cuadrado perfecto entonces también lo
podemos factorizar 25 no tiene mitad
tampoco es divisible entre 3 tampoco
entre 4 pero sí entre 5 es lo mismo que
5 x
estás de acuerdo y así para identificar
los cuadrados perfectos debes de
preguntarte hay aquí algunos factores
que tenga al menos dos de ellos y bueno
si las respuestas que tengo dos por dos
déjame ponerlo con este color tengo 2
por 2 y bueno también tengo 5 por 5
déjenme ponerlo con este otro color
también tengo 5 por 5 así que esta vez
voy a escribir la raíz cuadrada de 200
de la siguiente manera esto va a ser
igual a quien voy a tomar la raíz
cuadrada un poco más grande y bueno voy
a poner aquí a estos factores me va a
quedar
2 x 2 déjenme ponerlos con este color 2
x 2 x y después voy a escribir 5 x 5
para que te sea más claro los cuadrados
perfectos
5 x 5 y esto a su vez por 2 no olvidemos
este último 2 y esto por 2 y recuerda
los escribí en este orden para que
puedas ver más claramente los cuadrados
perfectos y bueno esto va a ser igual a
quien esto va a ser igual bueno pues
esto nos va a quedar la raíz cuadrada de
2 x 2 déjame ponerlo así 2 x 2 tal vez
esto te parezca un poco monótono pero
esto es muy importante que lo veamos
porque quiero que veas que también
funciona bueno pienso que es una buena
manera de verlo de hecho ambos se
reducen al mismo método y es por eso que
vamos a seguir obteniendo la misma
respuesta nos va a quedar la raíz
cuadrada de 2 por 2 por la raíz cuadrada
bueno cinco por cinco déjame ponerlo con
este color cinco por cinco muy bien ya
esto habrá que multiplicarlo por la raíz
cuadrada de 2 por la raíz cuadrada de 2
muy bien ahora observa lo siguiente la
raíz cuadrada de 2 por 2 bueno estos
simples sencillamente es 2 y la raíz
cuadrada de 5 por 5 bueno pues estos
simples sencillamente es 5 y entonces me
queda 2 por 5 por la raíz cuadrada de 2
y bueno esto es exactamente lo mismo que
2 por 5 es 10 10 que multiplica a la
raíz cuadrada de 2 y bueno ya con esto
podemos escribir esta expresión de aquí
de la siguiente manera puedo poner a 1
entre 10 por la raíz cuadrada de 2
hay mucha gente a la que no le gusta
tener un radical en el denominador y si
quieres deshacerte de él lo que debes
hacer es multiplicar tanto el numerador
como el denominador por la raíz cuadrada
de 2 déjame ponerlo así voy a
multiplicar tanto arriba como abajo por
la raíz cuadrada de 2 tanto el numerador
como el denominador ahora observa que la
raíz cuadrada de 2 entre la raíz
cuadrada de 2 esto simple y
sencillamente es 1 estamos expresando al
1 como raíz cuadrada de dos entre raíz
cuadrada de 2 pero esto nos va a ayudar
a que quitemos este radical de aquí
porque esto nos va a quedar bueno 1 por
la raíz cuadrada de 2 es la raíz
cuadrada de 2 y abajo abajo que me va a
quedar bueno me va a quedar 10 por la
raíz cuadrada de 2 por la raíz cuadrada
de 2 cuando es eso bueno la raíz
cuadrada de 2 por la raíz cuadrada de 2
eso es lo mismo que dos estás de acuerdo
y 2 por 10 es 20
así que ya está ya tenemos la respuesta
correcta que inclusive en esto mismo se
puede ver de la siguiente manera como 1
sobre 20 que multiplica a la raíz
cuadrada de 2 al final todas estas
formas son formas equivalentes para ver
la misma raíz cuadrada así que espero
que hayas encontrado esto bastante útil